[音楽]
こんにちは
中級でというわけで私さとみシャツを新居
に引っ越したものの家具がまだないんです
よ今3件の号でには家具という殻が全く
ないんですよちょっと前の動画で
クッションめちゃくちゃたくさん買って
さあ県の某て運んだんですけども保護費
組み上げましたもう何も私の家には残って
おりませどうしましょう
かいますというわけでですねちょっと
さすがにここで入れる動画とか取り出し
さっき音がしたいんですけどもできない
ぐらいにものなさなので2部活とかもう
ちょっと欲しいなと思いましてちょっと
ネットで何も考えずにとりあえず麦芽へし
ていこうと思います僕は張れば絡めても何
も考えずにも目に入ったものなんで欲しい
かと思ったもをつける人を持ってるかって
ことメモeditor
はいというわけで早速買っていきましょう
と旧帝集サイト今回使って行きたいと思い
ますでそん中でもですねこのハロ小切手
ピンズがめっちゃ安いんですよほんと激安
の韓国コスメとが買えるみたいでちょっと
ここで書くとかももちろんなんですけども
激安移動がに使えるものとかた江戸のとか
もついでに買っていきたいとおもいます
あ
いい
ユーチューバーを進めてるんだすごい
を月組終わるこれはもう帰りましょうたい
ですね枚さまで最安値って書いてあります
ねうわぁすっげますね韓国料理とかコスメ
がめちゃくちゃ安く売ってますねまあ希少
品とかも結構ありそうすごいなんか日本だ
と見たことのないような着ぐるみコスプレ
3だけ熱がありますねこんなにまず見た
ことないっすよ他のサイトに3たことない
んですよ買っておきますがこれ韓国料理と
いえばこの激辛のラーメンとかですよね安
っす
めっちゃ安い夏とこれも非常食として買っ
てきますちんじゃまず全然まだないん
だろうとか編集者で肩こりとかやばいんで
すぐ使えるのマッサージ機とかを買って
行きたいと思いますあり自然なんか
ジョイントとかずついてでいろいろ使え
そうですねはいこんな感じでちょっと
色んな書くとかもどんどん勝っていき
ましょう
という意味でようやく可能なものが届き
ました見てくださいこの数本当に使える
テーブルとか椅子とかを持つ論を買ったん
ですけどもなんかちょっとした時に食べる
食べ物とかあと動画で歌えそうな小物とか
も結構買いました今回で一気に30点
ぐらいものを買ってしまいました短編の
うちちょっと5大手水が押されなくてこの
空気感に合う家具とかきっこまず難しかっ
たてかなり選んで買わせていただきました
じゃあ動画にかけせるものをもちろんある
んですけどももちろんインテリア角度花王
されな結構買ったんで俺の工程カスさらに
カッコよくなること間違いなしというわけ
でさっそく開けていきましょう
ああああ
立っはあああああ
a
meさあああああ
いやー
いやぁああああああ
バーン
re
a
はっはっは
そういうわけでむずい覚えた荷物全部を
開けることができましたーーー
ああああああああああああ
皆稼働でこの家具の量を書くだけではなく
て動画で使えそうなものとかマッター
できると間接照明とか犯してもいろんな
ものを買ったので早速の届いたものを使っ
て心境を改造していきましょう
[音楽]
はいというわけで豪邸かなり変わりました
ちょっとこの辺いかつは広すぎて
めちゃくちゃそんな母と揚げじゃなくての
思えば机が1本だけでソード+かいます
そして和室
絶海作りが結構釣れているというとは
ちょっとざまな1持った時とかもあったの
ででもう終って小さいっていう置かせて
いただきましたソファーをたくさん大分で
たくさんの人が集まれるようになったので
はないかなと思いますお洒落な照明も
たくさん買いましたそしてこちらインテル
鋭角ではないんですけどもお菓子とか
しまったんですけども韓国のラーメンとか
あと動画で使えそうな器具にも安かったん
でたくさんちゃいましたそちらの
マッサージ機も開封したこれで広
方とか解せそうです今回9点使ったんで
めっちゃくちゃやすくいろんなものが
たくさん買えました大満足でございますで
今回この爆買したサイトの9点なんです
けどもサイト内容ですね韓国の最新
トレンドがそろった彼のこれというページ
があります
日本ではまだ手に入りにくい韓国のコスメ
やファッション
そしてこれ動画をなんかこういうの見た
ことあるんですけども多分日本で見たこと
ないようなやつもあったりしたのでぜひ
とも1回皆さん見てみてくださいさらに
なんとハロこり送料が無料になっており
ますめでとうございますん
そして腹今夜ですね韓国の公式ブランドを
たくさん掲載されておりますので今
ちょっとこれらの影響で韓国とかいけない
と思ってる方とかぜひお勧めでございます
詳しくは動画概要欄がチェックできますの
でぜひ皆さんハロー子にチェックしてみて
くださいじゃーん
あっは
[音楽]
bl